have you guys figured out when you're
filming this movie yet tomorrow you're
filming it tomorrow yeah are you excited
yeah
[ __ ] it's time to get into movie mode
that's what i mean by a step away do
they put you in with like uh i mean
obviously i'm assuming you're decent at
basketball just based on your bars um
but uh do you like have to go get with
like a [ __ ]
trainer to get your jump shot down type
[ __ ] so you don't look crazy on on on
the movie like and if so who's the
trainer
he's uh he's a low-key guy
it's not like he's not one of them chris
brickley or nothing yeah shout out chris
so i've worked with him but no this guy
that i've been working with is a
he's a family man i'll just say that
family man normal guy just so it happens
if you go to basketball exactly great
guy too what are acting lessons like
because i'm assuming you've taken some
of those yeah i've been working with
this uh this woman that's just brilliant
and um
she surprised me at how
exciting the lessons can be and how
connected
how connected the music is to acting how
many threads there are that make it feel
similar i don't know it's it's ill
i mean if this is going to be anything
like the first movie you might have a
rosie perez your version of rosie perez
i have a woman in the video are you are
you excited um to get your first like
on-air makeout sessions in and [ __ ] like
that you mean yes maybe a little
shirtless plays
maybe a little post-sex like get up put
your basketball shorts on go hit the
[ __ ] venice beach type [ __ ] i'm
i'm looking forward to everything that's
coming with it